ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt um meine lieben freunde ihr seht
ich befinde mich in einem baumhaus denn
hier hat ja die letzte folge auch
geändert und zwar mit der kisten und
item sortierung was wir heute für ein
ziel haben habe ich ja ebenfalls bereits
in der letzten folge gesagt und zwar es
ist die willicher insel
die soll nämlich hierhin kommen bevor
wir uns allerdings um die willicher
insel kümmern hole ich erstmal meine
items hier vorne aus der kiste wieder
raus was stimmt kommt mit balu ich kann
dir zeigen wo draufpacken kann ist und
zwar hier vorne auf die schildkröteneier
die seit jahren nicht wachsen ja los wie
du willst dich drauf packen ich habe dir
im jahr 1974 gepflanzt und diese immer
noch nicht ich las die spiegeleier davon
einfach mal in ruhe und meine lieben
freunde zum thema ruhe müssen wir auch
jetzt erst mal ganz kurz kommen denn ich
habe schon lange keine schweigeminute
mehr für die verstorbene katze die
verstorbene kuh
und die restlichen verstorbenen pilz für
eingelegt was dem einen oder anderen
hardcore zuschauer dieses let's play
wahrscheinlich direkt schon auffallen
wird ist dass ich einige einstellungen
bei meinem shader verändert habe wie sie
zum beispiel dass dinge die weit weg
sind jetzt in leichten nebel gehüllt
sind hier hinten die insel auch das
finde ich sehr schön und ich habe die
wollten ein bisschen filigraner
gestaltet und ich habe auch noch eine
weitere ziemlich krasse sache zu meinem
shader hinzugefügt wollen scharf ok dann
hey du kannst mich aber anschauen schön
ich habe auf jeden fall noch eine
weitere sache zum solche undankbaren
arschlöcher hier ich habe noch eine
weitere sache zum shaker hinzugefügte
allerdings könnt ihr euch die sache erst
anschauen sobald die vergiftung
eine pfütze so ekelhaft die andere
krasse sache die ich meinem shader noch
hinzugefügt habe kann ich euch leider
erst bei nacht zeigen und auch nur im
schnee wieder um die übelsten profi
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich schon wissen
was das ist und ich freue mich auch
schon mega euch das zu zeigen weil es
unfassbar schön aussieht allerdings
werden wir das am ende der heutigen
folge machen und da werde ich euch gerne
dann auch meinen kleinen tipp geben wenn
ihr euer minecraft auch ein bisschen
schöner haben wollt jedoch nicht jetzt
er hat die ganzen kapazitäten habt und
das budget hat um euch einen riesigen
gaming pc zusammen zu stellen allerdings
würde ich sagen mach ich jetzt mal ganz
kurz zu teilen wie ich bin die sachen
für die willicher insel zusammenhang
suchen was da jetzt gerade die nacht
anbricht und ich meine erde gerade
punktgenau zu ende abgebaut habe würde
ich sagen haben jetzt auch mal ganz kurz
dorthin wo ich euch das neue feature von
meinem shader zeigen kann und zwar seht
ihr hier vorne ja schon ein schnee- und
damit hat auch ein bisschen was zu tun
denn wenn ich mich dem schnee bis jetzt
ein bisschen näher hier vorne
beispielsweise mal ein brötchen
hinstelle und mich jetzt so richtig
dorthin bewegen also hier so hinlaufen
tag zu tag ich bin in den schnee
billionen brauche ich jetzt hier
beispielsweise mal ein bisschen hoch da
unten kommen direkt reaper die springen
mal hier auf den baum geht man hier
rüber so dass wir in kleinen ausblick
haben und ich gucke hoch in den himmel
[Musik]
egal
wir haben einfach polarlichter jetzt in
minecraft
ich habe wieder eine creeper party hier
ist etwas schade
sie können ihr denn die da so viele
krieger sein ich weiß nicht was ich
falsch gemacht habe ich hier sind auch
wieder über
[Musik]
was habe ich bei meiner welt falsch
gemacht dass hier so viele monster sind
ich verlasse das schnee um allerdings
wieder und würde sagen gefahren kurz
nach hause und gehen schlafen ich lege
mich jetzt einfach mal hier oben in
meinen baumhaus rheine und dann kann ich
euch am nächsten tag aber ganz kurz was
zeigen was sich auch erst überlegt habe
in meinem ein kraftfeld in den shader
mit rein zu programmieren und zwar
stelle ich mich dafür einfach mal nach
hier vorne da kann ich das nämlich am
besten zeigen und jetzt gerade sieht ja
alles hier so aus aber sie könnten es
auch so aussehen lassen
das ist jetzt so ein bisschen hier und
schärfe ihr seht schon wenn ich jetzt
irgendwelche dinge hier angucke dann ist
der rest unscharf um nur das was sich
anguckt ist auch hier zum beispiel die
schildkröte sind der hintergrund die
trasse aus oder hier wenn nicht wieder
die laternen gucke alles anderes
unscharf plus wenn ich mich schnell
bewege ist es ein bisschen haben das
habe ich mir nämlich auch gedacht ich
könnte mir einfach mal in die kommentare
schreiben
ich kann das ein lehrgang in kryta ist
tot was sich gerade sagen wollte war das
ihm ja einfach mal in die kommentare
schreiben könnte minecraft so besser
findet als mir dieser unschärfe hier so
ein bisschen ist extrem sympathisch und
schön haus zum spielen ist es jetzt aber
nicht so vorteilhaft oder ob ich das
lieber ausmachen soll ich kann euch ja
noch mal ganz kurz sie jetzt den
übergang hier zeigen ja also irgendwie
ist es so entspannt hat zum spielen aber
vielleicht sagt ihr zum angucken ist das
andere deutlich schöner schreibt mir
gerne auf jeden fall morgen in die
kommentare ich habe auf jeden fall eine
menge erde gerade geholt und würde sagen
dass ich jetzt noch eben den rest
zusammen suchen und dann fangen wir
endlich an mit der willicher insel
[Musik]
oh mein gott eigentlich läuft die
teilhabe ist eine kleine mini
schildkröte geschlüpft
moritz natürlich gucke ich dir ja du
bist ja plötzlich geschlüpft als einzige
da waren voll viele eier ich habe keine
ahnung wie ich jetzt diese horn schilder
von ihm bekommen soll das war der
eigentliche grund warum ich diese
schildkröteneier dahin gesetzt habe weil
ihr in die kommentare geschrieben hat
ein luca mit diesen schildern die
droppen solo bieli schildkröten da
kannst du dings waren megacool helme mit
den ganz unter wasser atmen
du willst wahrscheinlich gerade da
hinten ins wasser ich hoffe die
schildkröte glücklich alt wir machen
jetzt die times weiter
[Musik]
ich bin fertig meine lieben freunde an
alle die jetzt eventuell wieder sagen
sollten hey luca woher kommen die gras
blöcke der ist jedoch geschieht hätte
nee ich habe ja eine gold spitzhacken
mit behutsamkeit damit habe ich nämlich
die grabplatte abgebaut so dass wir
gleich ein bisschen entspannter hinten
auf der insel direkte schönen untergrund
haben ich würde allerdings sagen ich
fange erst mal an mit den see
rosenblättern denn die möchte ich
eigentlich ein bisschen so einsetzen so
perfekt und dann hier vorne noch einer
das auch gut hier auch sehr schön machen
wir noch so und so und dann würde ich
sagen können wir hier eigentlich schon
anknüpfen mit der erde da muss ich mich
ganz kurz unter wasser gehen und das
seerosen übertreffen müssen dass das
sagt dann machen wir hier die erde so so
so
und dann müssen wir aber auch noch oben
bist du dir plötzlich so nah hier vorne
soll dann auf jeden fall die willicher
insel so ein bisschen stattfinden bzw
werde ich hier glaube ich erst mal auch
so ein steg bauen wieder vorne dafür
habe ich nämlich extra dahinten das
lagerfeuer mehr mitgenommen nicht hier
habe ich auch mit der behutsamkeit
baustelle schaufel ich werde hier vorne
auch einen lagerfeuer steg bauen und dem
entsprechenden jetzt auch löschen damit
quasi genauso aussieht wie auf der
anderen seite
das ist unsere insel die sieht jetzt
zwar noch ein bisschen braun aus die
sache ist allerdings dass sich ja dafür
extra die gras blöcke mitgenommen habe
die können jetzt nämlich mal ganz
schnell nehmen und hierüber einfach
irgendwo an ein paar stellen hier zum
beispiel die hier hier hier hier hier
hier hier hier hier hier hier und hier
wie findet ihr mein kommentar
professionell oder hier werde ich jetzt
auf jeden fall so ein bisschen gras
blöcke reinsetzen damit das einfach
überhand gewinnt über die erde und damit
die erde einfach nach wenn ich mir nach
erde aussieht sondern nach erde mit gras
drauf
ich will immer in deutsch auch super
oder meine restlichen vier erde im
inventar werde ich jetzt auch mal ganz
kurzen nehmen um hier die fehler kurz
auszubessern wir können auch eigentlich
diesen baum hier endlich mal fällen
der stört mich auch schon die ganze zeit
so ein bisschen weil darunter einfach
hälfte sand und hälfte erde ist und ich
will ja eigentlich dass der komplette
belag unserer insel seiner karriere
schon wieder da muss wirklich die insel
reparatur 2.0 bald kommen ich will
eigentlich das alles sind es außer die
erste stufe aber hier zb ist dann auch
sand und so das muss ich alles demnächst
nochmal ausbessern
ich höre allerdings sagen wir
konzentrieren uns heute auf die insel da
hinten und ich schaue mal ganz kurz
ob ich sie eingepackt habe natürlich
habe ich das nicht und zwar möchte ich
auf der willicher insel genauso wie hier
vorne natürlich wenn man ankommt eine
schöne beleuchtung haben deswegen nehme
ich mir die stein ziegelmauern und
platziere die war habe ich die denn da
platziert hier genau hier und hier
und dann hier laternen drauf und sagt
ihr seht schon das gras frisst ein
bisschen durch die erde durch hier kommt
man dann an
hier kommt dann natürlich auch seinen
weg rom und hier stehen jetzt noch zwei
häuschen hab ich mir gedacht bei euch in
der heutigen folge erst mal und damit
wir fangen jetzt auch an und zwar würde
ich unser erstes häuschen gerne hierhin
setzen dementsprechend verteilen wir das
hier einfach mal so ein bisschen zum
beispiel hier ein bisschen cobblestone
dann hier wieder drauf so ein bisschen
hier dies also da können wir wirklich
das hinsetzen wir möchten hier noch ein
bisschen das sage ich ihr dann mal den
wieder in die ecke hier so also einfach
eine fünf mal fünf fläche aus
verschiedenen das ist das sieht nicht
nur 55 aus obwohl es 505 ist sagt und
sagt dann haben wir jetzt hier eine fünf
mal fünf fläche wo unser erstes häuschen
steht ich hole mal kurz die anderen
items guck mal wie geil das aussieht
wenn das da hinten so im nebel drin ist
dicker minecraft rock rap das schönste
spiel der welt und zwar bauen wir nun
den eingang für dieses häuschen ich
werde den eingang glaub ich hier
hinsetzen das wird er nicht ganz gut
passen und dafür nehmen wir zwei stein
ziege treppen können hier drunter jetzt
auch wieder die blöcke so ein bisschen
durcheinander setzen zum beispiel
einfach so dann nehme ich jetzt mein
reichen stamm und werde ich hier auf die
ecken solche kleinen pfeiler draufsetzen
zack zack und hier vorne orlow zack zack
und hier vorne die eichen holzbretter so
hinsetzen hier wird ein kleines fenster
rein kommen und hier kommt dann quasi so
in das häuschen rein
jetzt brauchen wir für hier noch ein
kleines gelände die müll- und dafür
nehmen wir einfach wieder unsere
altbewährten fichtenholz fallschirm
fichtenholz einfach das geilste in
minecraft finde ich hier müssen wir uns
jetzt ganz kurz helfen indem ich einen
blog gesetze da kann man nämlich jetzt
so machen und so machen dann kann ich
den blog hier oben wieder abbauen so
dass wir hier vernünftig rein können und
hier raus bilden wir jetzt so ein
bisschen das dach für das ganze hier
oben also und jeder an das dach hier an
den seiten können wir das einfach so
bauen und so bauen hier hinten werde ich
auch noch ein fenster einsetzen hier
soll nämlich so eine treppe hin und dann
kann hier zwischen ein süßes fenster
ständig vorne beugen
jetzt muss ich auch hier oben nochmal
aufs dach drauf erst mal eine krise jene
und du kommst hier hier vorne können wir
dann auf jeden fall noch mal so ein
bisschen weitermachen mit den
eichenstämmen und genau den gleichen
baumstämmen setzen wir noch mal hier
vorne hin jetzt muss ich allerdings erst
einmal ganz kurz zurück in einem
baumhaus laufen denn ich brauche
deutlich mehr licht neues treffen fällt
mir gerade auf das gute ist ja
allerdings dass wir in einer der letzten
folgen uns eine menge fichtenholz
setzlinge mitgenommen haben und von
daher keine sorgen mehr haben sollten
dass wir zu wenig richten heute haben
ich freue mich generell auch auf die
bauminseln ich weiß auch nicht so ganz
wie ich das machen soll ihr könnt mir
gerne in die kommentare schreiben falls
die tipps habt für die bauminseln tier
insel keine ahnung was ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir uns jetzt
erstmal mit dem dach ein bisschen
auseinander setzen dafür baue ich mich
hier mal ganz kurz hoch mit meiner erde
wir sehen auch schon die fast die ganze
insel ist schon voll mit gras und hier
setzen jetzt einfach kurz das dach dann
daraus mache ich euch mal eben ganz
kurze time labs
[Musik]
so leute ich habe gerade mal das dach
ein bisschen fertig gebaut ist hat sich
doch als komplex herausgestellt als ich
dachte
so sieht auf jeden fall gerade hieraus
ich kann es euch jetzt auch noch mal
ganz von der andern seite zeigen denn
dort habe ich einen kleinen das tier war
für mich damit ich da einfach vernünftig
hoch klettern konnte ich habe hier einen
kleinen wunsch da noch da vorne gemacht
beziehungsweise mir fällt gerade auf da
wollte ich eigentlich noch eine
steinmauer drauf setzen so dann sieht es
ein bisschen schöner aus ich weiß man
kann jetzt mit einem lagerfeuer arbeiten
dann braucht das so richtig aber das
können wir demnächst auf jeden fall
machen was ich hier an der seite
allerdings noch machen wollte war dass
das so vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen
schöner aussieht dann können wir auch
nochmal mich die noch genau wie die
schweine ziegen eben hier unten noch
dann sieht das vielleicht noch ein
bisschen besser aus glas brauche ich
noch fällt mir gerade auch auf und zwar
packen wir das glas jetzt einmal hier
vorne rein dann auch noch hier und hier
vorne da waren ja die fenster das heißt
von außen sieht jetzt so aus hier an der
seite haben wir den schornstein
hier haben wir ein fenster und von der
anderen seite ist kann ich euch mal eben
von innen zeigen bzw muss ich ja auch
noch hier die tür hinsetzen die kommt so
hin wieder nach innen gesetzt damit von
außen bisschen schöner aussieht ich weiß
jetzt ehrlich gesagt noch nicht so
richtig wie ich das hier drinnen machen
soll
ob ich hier auch noch so eine treppe
hinbauen soll habe ich noch welche man
jetzt einfach mal direkt kurzem
bruchstellen treppe provisorisch dann
können wir das beispielsweise hier so
und so machen hier drucker können wir
dann irgendwie ein fass setzen mit ich
habe jetzt gar keinen fall aber stellt
euch vor dass er einfach ein fass ist
und dann sind hier quasi 23 betten die
brauchen immer ein bisschen platz zum
schlafen damit die sich auf vermehren
können im boden hier den mache ich ab
es hätte der nachteil daran dass das
hier eine insel ist ich habe jetzt ganz
formal schnellen fasste kräfte dann seht
ihr wie ich das hier alle meine mit dem
fach seiner ecke deswegen mache ich
jetzt auch mal ganz kurz hier den boden
weg er setzte denen durch beispielsweise
jetzt einfach mal ein holzbrett boden
was schwieriges wort eichenholz brett
boden
wir stellen jetzt einfach mal hier so
eine fackel rein damit sie zumindest
nichts bond und das hier ist das zimmer
nummer eins oder soll ich das doch auf
die höhe hier bauen
ich weiß es nicht kann man es doch
überlegen ich möchte jetzt auf jeden
fall erstmal die insel fertig kriegen
und den ganzen feinschliff machen wir
dann am ende der folge jetzt brauche ich
allerdings das zweite gebäude und zwar
bei euch das nächste haus einfach mal
hierhin ich grenze das mal ganz kurz mit
den bruchsteinmauern ab und zwar hier
auch noch eine immer in drei blöcken
abständen hier zwischen bauen wir jetzt
cobblestone ist so und hier vorne auch
bam bam bam und hier auch bam bam bam
den eingang hierzu würde ich sagen
bauen wir auch einfach mal hier dann
können sie sich gegenüber immer begrüßen
wenn ihr eingehen so manche vorne
nämlich glaube ich eine berufsstand
treppe genau dann sieht so aus die tür
setzen dementsprechend nach innen dann
kann die hier schön abschließen hier an
den seiten auch erstmal noch so
bruchstein bisschen hoch bauen das wird
nach auf jeden fall noch schöner und wir
setzen uns auch ein bisschen durch
andere blöcke
aber hier sind gleich in welche richtung
das hier geht ich will jetzt nämlich
immer das gleiche ausbau und was wir nun
machen es einfach grobe erde nehmen und
strohballen und genießen das jetzt quasi
so ein bisschen durch zum beispiel hier
nochmal erde hier erde hier strohballen
hier strohballen erde
erde und dann machen wir da mal dass ich
jetzt genauso aus wie vorne waren wir
vorne noch einen strohballen setzen wir
jetzt auch mal so hin und dann hier
nochmal erde einfach hier in die mitte
mir das jetzt auch einfach so ein
bisschen durch sagt strohballen
strohballen und dann hier oben drauf
auch normal zack zack zack über einen
unfall oder dem baum glaube ich jetzt
auf jeden fall mal komplett gefüllte und
wir werden jetzt direkt rüber gehen ich
bin der aufnahme schon reichlich stunden
also ich muss mich jetzt echt ein
bisschen dran halten ich brauche mich
jetzt einfach mal hoch und werde hier
vorne jetzt eine
wie mache ich das jetzt sage ja das
funktioniert hier werde ich fichtenholz
stufen daran setzen das werde ich
überall so machen und hier vorne auch
dann hier wiederum um die ecke hier
vorne und hier und hier vorne an der
seite genauso ist es von euch eigentlich
von interesse dass ich euch die videos
wo ich mir die inspiration holte für die
ganzen sachen mal unten in die
kommentare schreiben beziehungsweise
unten in der infobox verlinke dann könnt
ihr mir das einfach mal schreiben und
dann werde ich das tun so dass ihr das
dann vielleicht ein bisschen besser
nachbauen können bzw
ich versuch's ja auch hier schon so ein
bisschen nachzubauen hier können wir
jetzt einfach mal unser gras nehmen und
dass sie so ein bisschen drauf rum
pflanzen sollen nämlich richtig verbucht
aussehen dieses häuschen und außen sieht
das ganze jetzt so aussieht schon aus
watte dass sie muss weg
von außen sieht das ganze jetzt so aus
ist schon süß
wir müssten den kommission glaub ich
noch ein bisschen mehr setzen ich
brauche jetzt einfach mal so ein paar
blöcke hier ab und werde die durch
andere blöcke ersetzen wie
beispielsweise durch andy sieht davon
habe ich noch so viel in der kiste
gefunden und in der hölle und dachte mir
einfach nur ich habe mich immer gefragt
wofür kann nicht sowas nehmen und bei
seinem haus sieht es glaube ich ganz
nice aus wenn nicht alles aus dem
gleichen material es sich nehmen jetzt
auch noch mal ein bisschen stein und
kann den jeder noch so ein bisschen hin
packen dann sieht zumindest noch so ein
bisschen clean aus stein siegel würde
ich jetzt glaube ich eher nicht nehmen
dann sieht es glaube ich ein bisschen zu
clean wieder aus wie oft habe ich jetzt
gerade ein bisschen und clean gesagt ich
finde das so schön mit diesem nebel so
eine kleine kleinigkeit aber ich finde
das macht einfach so ein kleines
stückchen schöner
wir konzentrieren uns weiter auf unser
häuschen hier vorne noch ein anti sieht
hin und hier dann sieht auch die seite
ein bisschen verbuchte aus und hier
nämlich beispielsweise mal den block weg
den dänen und dann noch den hirten der
mitte da werde ich das ganze jetzt
einfach mal so machen wir können wir ein
paar bemooste steilen auf jeden fall
noch mit rein setzen dann mache ich
beispielsweise den er setzt sich auch
nochmal durch den firmen mussten
bruchsteinen dann
hier vorne auch noch ein hin ich glaube
diese bau folgen sind extrem ohne
interessant zum zuschauen aber es muss
halt einfach aus sein wir werden jetzt
auf jeden fall ein paar fenster noch
leere einsetzen und zwar werde ich für
die fenster einfach jetzt mal die brust
1 treppen nehmen und die hier so
hinsetzen haben wir nämlich hier so ein
kleines fensterchen ohne dass wir so
richtig glas verwenden
das gleiche werde ich hier vorne jetzt
auch noch machen da haben wir hier dann
nämlich auch so ein fensterchen und hier
hinten auch noch mal das werde ich aber
dann glaube ich ein bisschen anders
hinsetzen was tut man moment ich glaube
ich mach das ja okay dass ich nicht so
gut aus ich glaub ich muss dann doch
genauso wie auf den anderen seiten
nämlich zeigt und sagt wir können
generell so ein paar blöcke einfach
nochmal durch so ein bisschen stufen
beziehungsweise treppen hier ersetzen
das liegt glaube ich auch ganz schön aus
die vorne könnte ich noch eine nehmen
die setzt jetzt beispielsweise mal so
hin und hier können wir das ganze dann
auch noch mal eben machen ich weiß nicht
wie das hier aus sieht doch dass ich
auch dann schön aus und dann nehmen wir
hierfür auch noch mal eine treppe und
setzten die sohin von innen sieht das
ganze jetzt so aus das müssen wir alles
noch ein bisschen schöner machen ich
werde jetzt erstmal wieder eichenholz
bretter hin packen genauso wie es im
anderen gebäude gemacht habe und die
eichen holzbretter hier einfach mal bamm
bamm bamm bamm bamm bamm mehr habe ich
jetzt gerade nicht deswegen noch einmal
ganz kurz hier welche geholte zac und
sagt hier bekommt die person auch eine
kleine fackel in die ecke wird alles
noch ein bisschen schöner gemacht
allerdings war das hier das ist unser
zweites gebäude und jetzt können wir
unsere chancen einfach mal nehmen und
hier den weg so ein bisschen lang
ballack der geht dann hier natürlich
selbstverständlich rüber zum ein gebäude
und hierüber zum anderen gebäude und
dann gehts hier quasi noch wartet moment
den weg hier mache ich gar nicht ein
bisschen anders und setzt sich so hin
dann nehme ich meine erde hier kurz
wieder macht das so dass sie glaube ich
ein bisschen besser aus wenn er dann
hier direkt um die ecke geht dann können
jetzt auch mal ganz kurz noch mal eben
das knochenmehl nehmen und hier alles so
ein bisschen verrucht aussehen lassen
hier um die ecke hier
hier hier vorne dann können wir auch mal
hier um das gebäude herum laufen zack
zack zack und noch hier und hier und
hier vorne
der weg geht dann hier vorne noch weiter
vielleicht können wir noch irgendwie
eine farm hin baut oder noch andere
gebäude
allerdings würde ich sagen dass das erst
mal warum zählt ihr zusammen auf meinem
boot ich habe mich gerade noch dazu
entschlossen hier auch einen schornstein
draufzusetzen nicht ob das sieht auch
ganz schön aus von innen klar als ich
das jetzt so aus irgendwie das kann man
zur not noch mal weg machen das hier
werde ich auch mal ganz entfernen ich
weiß nicht warum ich da so dass zur
komischen platziert habe so dass sie
doch einmal deutlich besser aus die tür
kommen jetzt mal schließen
und jetzt sieht unser mein kräften dorf
beziehungsweise widget auf so aus ich
bin richtig stolz
wir können das ganze noch mal oben aus
unserem baum aus angucken ich weil ich
bin jetzt bei zweieinhalb stunden
sondern habe ich schon lange nicht mehr
aufgenommen
allerdings hat sich gelohnt es hat sich
ich bin richtig stolz klar okay ein paar
leute damit wahrscheinlich erwartet dass
sich hier in new york bauer oder so aber
es soll ja alles so ein kleiner süßer
druck sein von daher bin ich auf jeden
fall begeistert wenn euch das heutige
video dann auch gefallen hat meine
lieben freunde dann lasst doch gern
einen daumen hoch da abonniert main
kanal und wie bereits zu beginn des
heutigen videos gesagt habe ich auch
einen kleinen tipp für euch wenn ihr
minecraft auch immer ein bisschen
schöner spielen wollt und zwar sieht
euer minecraft wahrscheinlich so aus ein
bisschen langweilig ich setze mir ganz
gut zur fackel hindern ist es ein
bisschen heller hier vorne in den
bereichen
das kann man allerdings schnell ändern
indem man einfach gedrückt und dann seht
ihr schon wie krass dass hier aus sieht
ihr seht allerdings auch das ist
generell ein bisschen anders ist vom
inventar als meine minecraft version das
hier ist nämlich nicht minecraft ja war
womit ich nämlich spiele sondern
minecraft für windows 10 das kann man
sich einfach im microsoft store
runterladen und dort gibt es nämlich
dieses geile feature wenn ihr eine
nvidia-grafikkarte habt und zwar heißt
dass nvidia rtx da gibt es ganz viele
kostenlose welten unter anderem auch
nicht nur dass hier sondern auch das
kolosseum in rom und so weiter und so
fort und da seht ihr wirklich dass
minecraft normalerweise so aussieht
allerdings hier mit einem integrierten
shader so und das ist extrem geil denn
wenn man keinen kranken gaming pc hat
wie ich und sich den shader irgendwie
selbst zusammen coded und selbst
installieren muss und bleibt dann hat
man es hier quasi direkt installiert in
minecraft drin ist läuft deutlich
flüssiger das sieht jetzt auf youtube
wahrscheinlich nicht wahr dass sie auf
30 fps runter gefragt ist allerdings an
alle die sich hier mit aus kennen die
wissen wie krass ist dass man in
minecraft implementiert schon ein shader
hat das bietet wirklich extrem viele
möglichkeiten zum modeln und generell
diese ganzen texturen und so das sieht
extrem krasser aus also wenn ihr euer
minecraft auch ein bisschen schöner
haben wollt dann braucht ihr keine
riesig kranken gaming pc für 10.000 euro
sondern einfach
[Musik]
nvidia ist geil und mit nvidia ist so
etwas möglich
ich werde für mich bezahlt dass ich das
sage aber das ist ein kleiner tipp für
euch
nvidia ist cool dieses projektes cool
ich bin todes müde ich hoffe euch
gefallen wir sehen uns übermorgen wieder
einem neuen computer city
[Musik]